what we're going to talk about today are
sets of positive numbers okay and a set
is basically just a collection of
positive integers and what we're going
to do is try to add sets together so
let's say we have a set that's called a
and will write the notation and I'll
give an example this set is 2 3 7 let's
have another example we'll call it B and
we'll say it B is 1 5 8 & 9 what we want
to do is add these two sets together and
so what do I mean by that what we're
going to do is add each number in the
set pair wise so I'll say that a plus B
is equal to 1 + 2 1 + 3 8 + 3 + 2 9 + 3
+ 9 + 7 right we have a new set and we
would like to write out the the sums so
that we actually know what our set is so
let's say 12 and finally 16 well we have
some repeated numbers here so we would
like to just write the set in its actual
form so I just struck out the repeated
numbers that we had so another thing
worth noting here is that in our set a
we had three members and our set B we
had four members and in our set the sum
of a and B we had nine members and this
is something that will come up again
we can think of a special type of set
that I'll call our etheric progression
so as my progression could be P equal
four eight twelve sixteen six twenty we
add for each time to the number before
it and we have a progression and it's
called an arithmetic progression because
we added numbers what we'll do is we'll
add P to itself and we'll see what
happens and something kind of
interesting kind of happens and so again
we have four plus four four plus eight
we have this large set of psalms here
and in fact the actual set will be much
smaller eight C twelve sixteen thirty
six and forty that's the final that's
the final set came down quite a lot
didn't is it normal for sets to come
down that much no it's not normal so if
we have a set of integers we add all the
sums we have you saw we had a lot of
sums in most cases maybe there's not too
much overlap in that case we have
something close to what we had
originally this whole large grid of
songs the nice thing about an arithmetic
progression added to itself is that the
the size of the subsets will be less
than two times the size of the original
set the sum set will never double the
the size of the original set what you
end up having is that the size of P plus
P is always less than or equal to two
times the size and that's special we can
do it another example where we get
pretty much the exact opposite maybe you
are size of P plus P is actually closer
to what we expect with no overlap so
what we're going to do next are at
geometric sequences I'll call it G this
time and this set will be 2 or 8 and 16
this is 2 to the 1 2 squared 2 cubed and
this is 2 to 4 so I'll add G to itself
this is a geometric sequence to itself
and what special about geometric
sequences is that they're pairwise songs
we have some overlap we have some
overlap here but we don't have overlap
as much as we do in the case of the
arithmetic progressions so the size of G
originally size for the size of
G + G is now equal to 10 and that's more
than doubled yes definitely more than
double all right so now we have the size
of G Plus G greater than 2 times the
size of G and if we were to take a
really large geometric sequence we would
actually see that G Plus G is about G
squared the first thing is a result from
Paul erudition it's about it's a little
bit about some sets okay so let's say we
take a set two three and seven we can
define the notion of set being some free
and what do I mean by some free I mean
that if you take any pair of numbers in
your set including the number itself
added to itself then the sum of the pair
of numbers is not in the set so let's
look at a plus a yeah and so this will
be 4 5 9 10 and 14 you see that no
numbers are shared between these two
sets okay so a is some free a some free
sets common or they like a special
rariti like prime numbers or some phrase
that's easy to find you would think that
they would be maybe uncommon but in fact
they're actually more common than you
would imagine so let's say you have any
set okay any set of positive integers
what Paul pearl area showed is that
there exists a subset of that arbitrary
set that you picked that is some free
and that subset is greater than a third
of the size of the original set yeah I
have a favorite a fractal set I'll say
in that it's inside of an interval of
real numbers so let's say you have an
interval real numbers 0 to 1 so we're
not dealing with integers and we're not
dealing with integers anymore we have a
set of real numbers what I would like to
I guess construct is something that's
called the Cantor middle third set it's
an iterative process on the first step
of the Cantor mil third set is you take
the middle third out of there the
interval 0 1 okay so you find the middle
third of 0 1 and so this goes from 1/3
to 2/3 and you erase that step segment
of the
what I have left is this set okay still
infinitely big yeah it's I mean if you
just count the elements on the side it's
huge it's uncountable so now the second
step is to take the middle thirds out of
the segments that we have left so we
take 1/3 of this set third and so we end
up with something a little smaller you
do it again and you do it infinitely
many times I suppose and the last thing
the limit said that you end up with is
called the Cantor middle third side but
you never get that how would you ever
get there well you approximated
basically you say that it's you know the
thing that if you get close enough or
you take an arbitrarily large step in
our progression that'll be the closest
set to it that'll be a woman how many
numbers are in the cantle middle third
set well their account uncountably many
okay and so in some sense you know you
can say that it's we haven't taken the
size down any at any point but there is
a way to measure how much we taking away
in general will say that the interval I
suppose is just a line if we want to
measure the dimension of the interval or
we can say that dimension is 1 all right
so the dimension just like the dimension
of this piece of paper should be it's
not actually 2 right because this has
some thickness but in some fantasy world
it's two right here in three dimensions
right okay so the dimension of the line
should just be one or the interval
should just be one and there's some ways
to measure the dimension of this counter
one third set and what I'll just say it
here and I'll call it dimension in
quotations and I'll say that the
dimension of Cantor said log two over
log 30
numberphile is brought to you by the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
MSRI that's the building behind me there
this is a place where many of the
world's top mathematicians come together
for sometimes a semester at a time
cracking some of the hardest problems in
mathematics if you'd like to find out
more I'll put some links in the
description under the video